so you might remember the birther
movement which claimed that barack obama
was not
actually eligible to be president
because of some combination of he was
born in kenya
or he was indonesian or his dad was an
american
or he once ate dog meat in indonesia you
know like whatever the explanation was
it was a ridiculous idea barack obama
was born in hawaii
but it was a hugely racially tinged
movement which actually donald trump was
at the front
and center of uh trump was one of the
loudest and most
prominent birthers for a period of
months if not more than a year talking
about barack obama's birth certificate
and the entire thing
now within mere hours of kamala harris
becoming joe biden's running mate
the birthers are instantly back it's
almost like
if you're not white they question
whether you're really an american that
seems to be the underlying theme here
subtly subtly being put forward now i
on the one hand i don't want to give
this too much oxygen but i do want to
lay it out generally for you a guy named
john eastman tweeted quote
is kamala harris eligible for the office
of vice president
here is my article published by newsweek
exploring the issues
short answer it depends now
why newsweek even published this at all
is a good question
eastman teaches law at chapman
university
and is a fellow at the claremont
institute if you research the claremont
institute you'll find that they're a
right-wing think tank that was
supportive very early of donald trump
and it stuck to trump and trumpism
uh like i don't know super glue whatever
metaphor you want to use
now of course kamala harris was born in
oakland california
what possible argument would there be
that she's not
eligible to be the president or vice
president now remember
in order to be vice president you have
to be constitutionally eligible
to be president so that's why it's
relevant the argument is
i i hope you're ready for this harris's
dad is jamaican
and was not an american citizen when
kamala harris was born
in i believe it's 1964. kamala harris's
mom
is from india uh and she
was not a u.s citizen at the time that
kamala harris was born
in oakland california thus kamala
is not a natural-born citizen and thus
could not be
vice president because she is ineligible
to be president of the united states
now in the article eastman goes really
into the weeds with arguments about the
14th amendment and the definition again
i mean it's like barack obama number two
the arguments about what does it mean to
be natural born
it's obama birtherism redux and and by
the way
they are only pushing it further by
saying this isn't only the law
today it's about what the founders
meant when they established how
citizenship is conferred and we can't
just look at court
decisions today although they have some
court decisions they
claim suggest kamala is not eligible
it's also about interpreting the
desires of what the founders meant
hundreds of years ago now there is a lot
more to this
there is actually a real law
conversation that could be had
but in practice it's only being applied
to barack obama and now to kamala harris
in practice this is the same racist
birtherism that we saw with barack obama
and
my instinct is and i hope that this is
the case i don't think it's going to get
a lot of pickup
and part of the reason why isn't going
to be because it's completely baseless
factually
which it is completely baseless
factually with obama it was about the
president
with kamala harris it's about the vp and
i think that may keep it
from getting the attention it it
otherwise might and of course
you know no one said this about john
mccain born in panama they're just fine
accepting well it was a military base
and thus it's fine
nobody said this about ted cruz when he
was a candidate for the republican
nomination in 2016 even though he was
born in canada
as you may or may not know current
british prime minister boris johnson
was an american citizen because he was
born i believe it was in manhattan
uh although he has since renounced it
that's no problem but
is kamala harris born in oakland
eligible to be vice president all of a
sudden now
they have questions it's the same dog
whistle stuff and it's almost
it's too predictable it's too on the
nose
that this is the direction immediately
you have some pro-trump think-tank legal
scholar
talking about let's sort of hope that
this is it but i did want to let you
know that it was going on